[Music]
so Nintendo's new 3ds systems are coming
out in just a few days in North America
and if you're a big monster hunter or
Zelda fan you've probably pre-ordered
one of these systems either the Monster
Hunter 4 ultimate limited edition or the
Majora's Mask limited edition case
you're wondering what you're expecting
or maybe what you're missing out on
we're gonna open these up real quick and
give you a quick unboxing and let you
know what's inside so the Monster Hunter
ultimate edition new 3ds comes with your
usual manual and AR cards you've also
got the system itself which has a sort
of a feather brushed finish to it now
like every other new 3d SS for sale this
does not come with its own AC adapter it
says so right in the box
so you're gonna have to buy one of those
you will not have to buy Monster Hunter
4 ultimate because that comes
pre-installed on the system and the
contents of the Majora's Mask 3d s are
basically the same again you've got the
manual AR cards and the system itself
this one has a gold finish and the Skull
Kid mask on the front now unlike the
Monster Hunter Ultimate Edition 3ds this
does not come with the game you're gonna
have to buy this separately if you want
to play Zelda on your Zelda 3ds
[Music]
so apart from the exterior elements that
are unique to each of these models the
inside of both of these systems are
exactly the same and just like every
other 3dsxl that's coming out February
13th from Nintendo so if you want to
know more about the new 3dsxl systems
feel free to check out our review
unfortunately these models are currently
sold out to pre-orders but you can still
pick up the regular new 3ds XL models
when they ship on February 13th
[Music]
you
[Music]